this is a strange IQ because it is both
new and not new at the same time because
just like functions you've been using
inverse functions for a while we just
might not have known that's what they
were called okay so let me try to
explain what these are in a triangle
right we've been doing some trig and if
I give you a question like oh I don't
know something like this
let's go degrees and X now in this
triangle it's really easy to find the
under that's all we're always doing when
there's a prettier other question you
might find X okay what equation what I
write to find X in this case sign okay
pause for a second how do I know sine is
the ratio of time
okay very good from this point of view I
go opposite on hypotenuse that would
give me the values I moms are so I'm
gonna write sine 30 as you suggested
equals x over 4 that's what I meant to
say okay now sine 30 you can put that
into a calculator or if you're good
you'll know that's an exact value which
is why I picked it sine 30 what's it
equal to
aha okay so I've got 1/2 equals x on 4
so if I so good I'll just multiply both
sides by 4 and I get an answer
okay you're happy with that now this is
using this language here is using a
function sine is a function like you can
put an input in and you'll get an input
up you put in 30 degrees you get a huh
input/output okay but if I just very
subtly change the question right if I
change it to be this kind of question
you've seen loads of these now it's the
same triangle yes and I'm taking the
same number that you know so you already
know what theta is what its sizes okay
but how would I solve this question what
would I write
okay I'm going you know I still start
off the same way and I'm still gonna say
its opposite on hypotenuse you okay with
that I know the tour 4 is just 1 over 2
is just equivalent fraction right now at
this point if you didn't know what the
answer was you would reach for your
calculator and then you would put in
your press some particular buttons which
buttons would you press I mean a hug you
go shift right and then you press the
sign button now just mark this right
you're right
theta equals and this is what you'll
punch into your calculator and this guy
here we call sine inverse right sine
inverse you've got functions and then
you've got inverse function sine inverse
causing those tan inverse what is an
inverse function do
what's its relationship to the original
and the answer is it kind of it kind of
gets rid of this right like you had a
side you before and now it's kind of
vanished right another way of thinking
about it is it undoes whatever seinem is
doing here okay now you've got loads of
inverse functions in fact we've got some
of these here right so for instance see
from this line to the next slide right
what did I do to get from line 2 to line
3 in this equation do I multiply by 4
I'm not part of what way you can cross
multiply if you like now multiply by 4
why do I multiply my fault what's the
usefulness of that now what it will do
is we'll get rid of this denominator
right which is great but to use our
language here right of functions and
inverse functions dividing by 4 that's a
function right you're put in an input
like 40 and you get an output my tenth
right you put an input you get an apt
with division by 4 is a function and it
has an inverse it has another function
that will undo it right instead of
divided by 4 if you multiply by 4 that
will get rid of that operation get rid
of the function
it's just what sine inverse does okay so
he's only going to do
an example right let's take a function
right so this is an example of a
function right let's take a nice easy
straight line something like a little
bit possible okay now to undo this
function right to find the inverse try
to leave it like that what I want to do
is instead of getting enough taking an
input and getting an output remember I
said I want to go in reverse
right I don't want to put an input and
get the output I want to know if you
know what the output was can you tell me
the input does that make sense I'm
trying to go in the other direction so
being that I'm trying to I'm trying to
switch things around right what what
name have we given the inputs and
outputs in this equation we've just put
symbols on x and y right that's our
input and that's our output but I want
to switch them around I want to go in
the opposite direction so to find the
inverse function we swap the inputs and
outputs or to put it in symbolic terms
we swap the X's and Y's okay so if work
was 3x plus 4 is a function okay then to
get its inverse I just switch these guys
around right so I'm just gonna write
this in a different color x equals 3y
plus 4 you see I just swapped them just
swap them now this is fine but it's a
bit messy we usually like to write our
equations in this form this is gradient
intercept form right how do I put this
in gradient intercept form what might I
do
yeah I will almost right I want to
rearrange this not some sequel to zero
but so that why is the subject which is
very similar okay so I'm just going to
shuffle this around a little bit watch
with me I'll take away 4 from both sides
okay by the way the reason I take away 4
is because subtracting 4 is the inverse
function of adding 4 right functions
inverse Allah I'm only one step away
right what do I do to make Y the subject
divided by 3 I'll do that in one hit and
divide very huge so I'm going to get 1/3
X minus 4/3 okay now here's why I asked
you to get your computer right if you've
gone there before you get I find that
does that match what you expected does
that match what you expected the 3 tells
you it's got a great in of 3 so it's a
pretty steep thing right and the plus 4
tells you what is it possible to tell
you what it tells you the y-intercept
right which is up there at 4
you can just see it there right I've got
zero but now what I'm gonna do is if you
just just do here just keep them Tom and
you know started New York originally
it's up now I've got a choice here I
could write it like this
this got fractions that's because I'm
just gonna write this they're the same
equation do you agree just written in a
slightly different form let's write it
in x equals throughout the school
yeah okay now what have you got right do
you see I've got two functions of a
purple one well your colors might be a
bit different you must like these blue
and red I've just done a bit more weight
this way so they've given me new colors
I've got the first function in purple
and then I've got the inverse function
in orange do you see that it's just
before you but let's just try this
quickly with another example and this
time I'm not even going to do this one
we're just going to go straight here
okay I want you to take your first
equation right take away all the values
take away all about let's take something
like say parabolas would be spending a
lot of time on flowers right so let's
draw one that's good right X above the
arm above the number six on your
keyboard you should not be symbol that
looks like a on an upside down be like
this it's called a hat I want you to
type that hat and then press the number
two that will give you their names do
you see that X square minus 2 plus 1
that X square plus 1 you see it yeah
what's the inverse function of this
going to look like if there is an
investor I'm going to swap the X's and
Y's right so down here instead of y
equals f of X equals y square plus 1 now
what's going on here right if you do it
your straight lines there your purple
your orange your original and your
inverse they clearly related in an
important way here's what I want you to
do I want you to change your head I mean
I want MTV events I want you to turn
your head 45 degrees to the right
[ __ ] let's just turn that way and to
help
do you see what you've got
what you've got is actually a reflection
of one graph onto the other one yeah
this is just the beginning we're going
to dig further into what this means and
how to work with it on Thursday